[Musique]
à quoi pensez-vous jacquet
lagarde skis vareilles monsieur tel
rapport
mais la vie ne tient qu'à un fil
monsieur il faut tirer tirer est encore
tirée
vous êtes triste jacky
trouvez que c'est qu'est monsieur
d'avoir habité pendant 18 ans en face de
la gare d'estivareilles sans jamais
avoir entendu un train siffle et je vous
vends
nous quitter
ce sens
oui
m
et j'entends
aussi vrai
autre
que 7 6 4
ici le temps
soir
je
[Musique]
à j
tout seul
à part
sur le
les eaux
oh
des gens
suivez
là
et j'entends
que c'est triste
ici le temps
soit
g
il
oui
c'est ap
g
que c'est
en bas
c'est loin
or
oh
[Musique]
penser qu'ils veulent
mais je sens
[Musique]
nous t'aimons
les gens
aussi p
toi
et j'entends
j'entendrai
ce train toute ma
ja
la richard anthony bonsoir alors
j'entends siffler le train c'était en
quelle année 62 62 et qui est écrit
cette chanson paroles et musique la
chanson c'était un folklore américain
qui était écrit deux cents ans plus tôt
deux cents ans plus tôt je te jure
et il a retrouvé comment parce que tu
écoutes et toi tu écouté beaucoup là la
radio américaine la nuit non c'est ça
non mais attends tu veux que je vous
raconte ça va être très longue gc a
brisé mon grand père était diplomate
anglais en egypte là où je suis né alors
donc j'étais vert l'envi saxon situer et
tout ce qui est américain en double je
connaissais par coeur et se font corps
est resté dans ma tête pendant des
années des cerises et puis un jour je
dis quelle belle chanson il faut la
faire en français et c'est comme ça que
c'est parti je demandais à mon ami
jacques plan de faire des plans parce
que j'étais pas cap de les faire moi
même
c'est comme ça qu'on a sorti premier
tube de l'été en 1962 mur vert et contre
tous
la maison de disques emi on dit pas
question monsieur de sortir une chanson
lente polyter et cgt j'entends siffler
le train donc un peu l'inventeur du
cheveu de l'été en quelque sorte
est ce que tu sais combien ça rapporte
et j'entends siffler le train le fils
qui s'est attaqué aux jeunes et qu ils
savent
oui us donc ils tiennent nuitées compte
que toi ces structures et des coureuses
bout qui sont la règle comme ça tu sais
ce que tu as gagné on est copains on est
au diapason
je me suis pas tiré j'ai payé et me
disent richa à partir de maintenant il
faut être sérieux et ça et ça je dis ok
d'accord et donc à ce moment là on est
copains mais tu faisais quoi avant de
chanter les origines de ta famille alors
que ton père était ambassadeur de nos
grands bruns ton grand père était
ambassadeur de d'angleterre en egypte
c'est ça c'est là où je suis né au caire
en quelle année en 1938 c'est bien
internet
parce que jamais sa veste synchroniser
la vérité non mais j'ai 54 beurre et
quand on demande je dis juste 56 samedi
à claquer staff et dans ton père était
d'un grand père était ambassadeur sa
famille toi tu est élevé là bas non dans
du coton vous êtes venu vivre à paris a
proposé deux partis en argentine à vous
êtes revenu à paris c'est très compliqué
tout ça c'est le pari et j'adore la
france tout d'un coup que je découvre
pour la première fois qu'on met un
janson de sailly et mon père au bout de
deux ans il me dit on par milan en
italie
je dis non je reste en france et je
continue mes études en france c'est ce
qui s'est passé c'est toi tu as fait du
droit
et puis ton père tu as plus une
garçonnière dans pertes assez bien gare
solaire et du toit pour tous les toits
pouvant oui je les ai alors ton père te
paye la garçonnière et toi pour pour
quand même subsister à tes moyens je
vendais fric voilà tu viens vrp en
réfrigérateur courageux avec une voiture
de sport quand vous avez quoi comme
voitures une hausse qu'ils à bravo s'est
passé comme on l'avait prévu orateur
mais tu sais comment on faisait noir
après dîner on avait dans le 3è 4è
arrondissement où il y avait tous ces
chers amis d'afrique du nord qui
débarque et s'était pas plaint c'était
fin des années 50 et on mettait des
prospectus dans les boîtes aux lettres
dans la nuit tu vois en disant je passe
demain tu vois comme ça je serais pas
jeter il s'était déjà prévenu que
j'allais venir lors essayer de leur
vendre navarro ouais non c'est pas mana
c'est d'essayer de faire ce qu'il faut
faire et ce que je dis est alors un jour
quand même parce que l'histoire est
drôle un jour fut il ya un type et je
vais vous expliquer qui d'ailleurs qui
te dis mais si tu veux gagner de
l'argent il ya un truc que tu devrais
essayer quand même c'est le rock'n'roll
j'ai une famille absolument
ultra-puissante être vers le mans et
m'ont dit grâce à ton père nous avons
tous réussis
et alors nous sommes tous là derrière
toi pour te faire continuer des études
machin tu dois pas fini tu files ta
faculté de droit j'avais passé mon bac
première est filou agents sont en
faisant visiter d'ailleurs une fois
comme c'était la mode à cette époque là
et ensuite bon on m'a dit on va m'aider
j'ai dit ben non je voulais de le faire
tout seul et ils m'ont dit quoi je dis
je sais pas et un mois plus tard j'ai
dit j'ai trouvé le filon parce qu'il
fallait que je devienne aussi riche que
du route du jour au lendemain mais
c'était pas une question de pognon c'est
une question de réussite le standing de
parakou rapport aurait été bridée et je
leur ai dit j'ai trouvé alors ils m'ont
dit qu'est ce que c'est jeudi j'ai une
idée fabuleuse
il ya des musiques américaines de
paulhan caire des platters des délices
précis tous et c'est ça qui marche
fabuleusement bien comme je suis anglo
saxons la wii et que j'aime bien ce
genre de musée mais que je suis français
maintenant je trouve qu'en france il
faudrait chanter ça en français et j'ai
une idée
il ya une époque où certains à porter
des jeans d'autres importer des formules
de magazines toi tu as apporté des
chansons et usa traduit effectivement
quand tu avais une bonne voie ça
marchait assez rapidement quand ils
devenus c'est à dire j'ai promis aux
émergents je suis arrivé en 60 alors dit
moi ça c'était avant et après alors
qu'est ce que tu as fait après quand ça
a commencé a moins bien marché qu'est ce
que tu as fait qu'est-ce que tu avoues
jean n'a jamais moins bien marché mais
j'explique cette chose là pour les
téléspectateurs qui vous écoute tout le
monde a le droit d'avoir un samedi
dimanche où les jours de faire reprendre
devant nous jamais surtout quand on fait
tout tout seul et je me suis dit il faut
que je suis parti à saint paul de vence
mais je pensais y rester pendant trois
ou quatre mois finalement j'y suis resté
quatre ans mais j'ai rien fait ouais
mais j'étais en train de récupérer tous
ses week-ends et tout séjour de vacances
que j'avais jamais vu parce que quand
les gens sont en vacances
excuse moi du terme l'artiste lui
travaille en quelle année le fisc a
commencé à s'intéresser à toi 68 74 où
je me repose
moi je pensais partir six mois mais
pendant cette période là je me suis
enfin permis de vivre
j'avais commencé à travailler à 18 ans
j'avais plus de 30 ans à cette époque là
je ne suis payé une rolls excusez moi du
peu
mais cette époque là elle comptait 12
briques tu prends pas 150 que vaut
aujourd'hui donc j'allais le droit de la
voir
je me suis payé une maison à saint paul
de vence qui comptait exactement le
dixième jeu ça peut péter aujourd'hui
j'étais en plus voisins avec yves
montand et simone signoret qui était la
colombe qui était juste au dessus et
c'était une vieille suivante refuse je
suis un peu tous les trois ensemble on
n'arrêtait pas regarde jean est bon
pendant cette période là j'ai fait ce
qu'on appelle fiscalement et grâce à
tonton ça n'existe plus parce qu'il est
c'est un agrume un peu mieux qu'on
puisse dire
on m'a taxé par le prédécesseur que je
ne nommerai pas on m'a taxé des éléments
de train de vie
la rolls la maison machin etc alors donc
vous devez déclarer ce que vous dépensez
ça c'est le système français à fond et
tout le monde le sait du mois à ce
moment-là bon bah moi j'ai vécu pendant
quatre ans tu sais à l'aise breizh 0%
peur qu'un jour ça j'ai mon retomber sur
la tête
j'étais en train de claquer simplement
quelques économies parce que j'avais
laissé tout mon fric à mon ex femme
parce que c'est ma façon de faire mais
alors qu'est ce qu'ils t'ont fait payer
le fisc c'est le gendarme delà de la
localité où j'habitais l'acropole il m'a
dit richer nous avons une petite
histoire entre nous que c'est quand vous
voulez mais sans rien me dire
alors je dis je peux il faut que je
viens tous et non non non non vous n'est
qu'on voulait alors je dis ok d'accord
je pensais que c'était une contenance
comme 7,60 mère alors qu'un jour plus
tard je téléphone au colonel j'arrivais
qui était utile et je lui dis que même
je pars en moto j'ai fait un tour en
moto j'avais mon plus beau de shopping
ouais et je suis en train de faire du
sport en moto parce que j'adore la photo
est ce que je peux passer toute l'année
alors il me dit mais ce des dents vous
voulez j'arrivais 16h30 et je m'assois
redisons de quoi s'agit-il
l'histoire la petite histoire il me dit
c'est pas une petite roche d es et vous
c'est grave jeudi guise de quoi
s'agit-il
il me dit vous devez 1 million 500 mille
francs d'arriérés au fisc français
et si vous ne donnez pas un chèque
certifié dans la demi-heure qui suit tu
parles c'est aux trente ans tu es
banques fermées dans lagardère a servi
de les extraire binger autre juste vous
emmener
ah bon toise et même un pataquès et
c'est comme ça que ça se passe une barre
c'est tout c'est là qu'ils étaient remis
en prison
oui et alors c'était comment la prison
fois remise par dix mois bons problèmes
avec le fisc
et puis aussi problème faut bien le dire
pour les pensions alimentaires que t'as
pas vraiment toujours bien payés rubis
sur l'ongle m'adore c'est un bonheur je
te soutiens sont jamais remariée elles
sont superbes mais des journées des
raisons des goûts de luxe péter pham
rifains ne m'en voulez pas savez vous
savez vous avez eu des amants et vous
les avez toujours des gens fantasment je
ne nommerai pas parce que ça ferait un
pataquès 1 et elles ont toujours eu tout
ce qu'il fallait
moi j'accuse mes enfants c'est ça qui
t'apporterai parce qu'ils s'adorent
entre eux et 10 alors maman arrêtez de
vous coltiner mais à noël dernier je te
jure c'est peut-être vous voilà un jour
2 voilà mais il faut le dire noël 91
tout le monde s'est retrouvé dont il y
avait les droits tv les quatre femmes et
onze enfants
pourquoi ouais grâce à mes enfants on a
passé une messe de minuit ex 3 en sus
ensemble alors entre le premier plein
ces trois femmes ma petite amie
huit enfants ce qui est normal jeu on
passe pas si tu veux dans la
clandestinité où l'horreur en faster
parce que moi j'aurais voulu garder dans
ma vie qu'une seule femme et d'avoir
simplement trois ou quatre fois mais le
métier est un métier tu en es qui fait
en sorte qu'on ait toujours séparés et
moi je n'étais pas fait pour me marier
quatre fois moi je voulais garder une
femme
bah oui une famille le film très belle
chanson là dessus en plus amoureux de ma
femme de 60 ans mais dark ale jet du but
à chaque fois en dix mois pour en
revenir à ta carrière tu là c'est drôle
tu le fais parler comme c'est drôle
c'est drôle pour en revenir à ta
carrière tu l'as vécu comment ce
changement de situation c'est à dire le
le passage quand même c'était
grosse grosse pouf vedette puis d'un
seul coup on était devenus îlots je sais
pas encore une grosse id
j'ai vécu comment ce changement de
situation on s'en fout c'est pas les
objets variés
tu vas te coucher avec une ferrari sa
soeur à coire 1 mais si tu l'aies devant
la porte ça fait plaisir a dit mme
richard maintenant tu dis à cannes tu
vis de quoi exactement
j'ai huit musiciens qui sont harper et
on n'arrête pas de faire des galas
ratifie les gala le samedi dernier nous
avons fait 3000 personnes à châteauroux
du fait des gars là tu fais des concerts
tout va bien c'est ton seul problème
finalement c'est ton poids quand même si
je peux servir maigrir vingt et un jours
à cause de ça je le premier problème
cardiaque il ya une douzaine d'années
mais ce que j'ai fait la cordée ayant
joué il ya quelqu'un à los angeles qui
m'a dit qu'ils étaient médecins chefs
vittel le sens d'huez
il m'a dit rich as tu continues comme ça
tu vas mourir
ouais alors l'histoire est alors le
corps tu vois tout d'un coup il se dit
comment on s'occupe plus de moi on me
fait plus maigrir ont fait plus de
détresse aux thérapies moyens et il a
grossi comme ça si je me suis fait
pousser une barbe c'est pour le double
montant le triplement toi c'est comme
pavarotti quoi c'est parce que j'ai vu
peu à bord ça parce que je la gauche
avec la jeunesse
qu'est-ce qu'il est beau et ça va mais
moi cette année j'ai décidé que la femme
la neige de rendez-vous si tu le bruit
c'est à dire parce que j'ai envie de
jouer au tennis et faire du ski nautique
et tout ce que j'ai fait avant je me
suis juré que petit à petit parce que
j'ai trouvé vraiment des gens
formidables je vais perdre 20 kilos
d'ici la fin de l'année
et en plus j'ai pas long de le dire
j'aime faire une liposuccion tu vas pour
enlever tous leurs acquis va pour nous
parce que quand on fait partie de ce
métier devant le public qu'on aime
duquel on dépend je pense qu'il faut
être présente à l'est pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous y mettez un peu de bleu